GINGER STRAND: OK.
So I think I'm
introducing myself today,
which is really kind of fun.
And I was trying to think
up some sort of Vonnegutian
introduction, like Ginger Strand
is the winner of the National
Book Award in the future.
[LAUGHS] But I'll
just be more straight.
I'm the author of four books.
The most recent one I'm
here to talk to you about,
"The Brothers Vonnegut,
Science and Fiction
in the House of Magic."
My previous two books are
also narrative nonfiction.
One is about interstate
highways and serial killers,
and the one before that
is the untold history
of Niagara Falls.
And an interesting thing, if
you're purchasing the book
today, is that the first
printing of this edition
screwed up the subtitles
of the last two books.
So there's a sort
of printing error
that maybe one day after I've
won the National Book Award
will be super, super valuable.
But, yeah, my last book was
not Killer on the Road, Beauty,
Power, and Lies.
But that could be
kind of a fun title.
What I'm going to
do today is talk
through basically the first
half of the book "The Brothers
Vonnegut."
I think it's more
fun just to talk,
as opposed to
hearing writers read.
And given that I'm
talking at Google,
I actually added to
the normal book talk
that I usually do
about this book.
I put in some of the stuff about
the dawn of the digital age
that I have taken out
in previous versions.
Because I was
thinking there might
be some fans of early
computers and things
like that in the audience.
So I just took that opportunity.
Because I kind of
geeked out myself
when I was writing the
book on that topic.
So I have this
nifty little thing.
And my first slide is a
picture of the Catskills.
And the reason is
because people always
want to know when you give
a book talk, why did you
write this book?
Like how did you
come to this story?
And most people assume
that since I wrote a book
about Kurt Vonnegut and
his older brother Bernard,
that I was a big Vonnegut fan.
And actually, I really liked
a couple of Vonnegut novels,
but I had not read
everything when
I started working on this book.
I came to this
book because I was
reading a history of New York
City's hydro infrastructure.
I'm a huge fan of
hydro infrastructure,
and I hope some of you are too.
I think it's a glorious thing.
And New York City's
hydro infrastructure
is especially exciting.
And so I was reading
about this obscure episode
that nobody seems to
know about in 1950,
where New York City
had not yet completed
the last of its reservoirs
up in the Catskills.
They had been halted first
by lawsuits from New Jersey
and Pennsylvania who were upset
at us for taking their water.
And then there was the
war, the Second World War.
And so in 1949, there
was a big drought.
By 1950, New York City
was running out of water.
And the "New York Times"
was actually publishing
on the front page a
little thing every day
that said, days until
water pressure runs out.
Like the water was going to
stop coming out of the taps.
And they had-- it was
really fascinating.
There were like shaveless
Fridays, and Thirsty Thursdays,
where you were supposed
to avoid drinking water.
The mayor stopped
shaving and grew a beard.
Volunteers were going door to
door, banging on the door like,
can we look at your plumbing
to see if you have leaks?
People were putting little
plastic swimming pools
on their roofs to collect water.
So it was really serious.
The city was going
to run out of water.
And so they decided to cloud
seed the Catskill Mountains
and make rain for
the reservoirs.
So they started cloud seeding
the Catskill Mountains
in early 1950.
They cloud seeded all
through the summer.
It rained all summer long.
The people in the Catskills
were really annoyed.
They're always annoyed at us,
but they were really annoyed
this time.
And then they continued
seeding, the city
continued seeding in the fall.
And in Thanksgiving, 1950, there
was a huge storm system that
went through to the Northeast.
And the floods in the
Catskills were devastating.
So New York City was slapped
with a couple million dollars
worth of lawsuits,
and the enthusiasm
for municipal rainmaking
kind of evaporated.
And I just was like fascinated
by that whole episode.
And then I found out that the
person who invented the method
and actually advised New
York City on this program
was Bernard Vonnegut, the
older brother of Kurt Vonnegut.
And knowing what I knew
about Kurt Vonnegut,
you know, that he nearly died
in a slaughterhouse basement
in the firebombing
of Dresden, I was
struck by this
beautiful juxtaposition
of one brother trying to
bring down rain from the sky,
and the other brother hiding
in a slaughterhouse basement
while fire is
raining down on him.
And I just thought, that
would be a really nice essay.
And hence, I wrote a book.
Because the more I looked into
it, the better the story got.
There were all these other
cool juxtapositions too.
Bernard was eight
years older than Kurt,
and they were kind
of like opposites.
They were at the two
ends of the family.
They had a sister in between.
And Bernard was this brilliant
science guy who went to MIT
and got a Ph.D. In chemistry.
He was the big
family success story.
He was the one everyone
expected to do something great.
The A student, the hard worker.
Kurt was kind of like the class
clown, the family screw up.
He had gone to Cornell,
majored in biochemistry,
because that's what his
brother told him he should do.
And he'd kind of flunked out.
And then joined the
Army, and that's
how he ended up in Dresden.
So I really liked this
the sibling rivalry
that they had, and
this kind of opposition
that they had between
the two of them.
And then I kept discovering
all these groovy, I don't know,
coincidences in a way.
So one thing that I discovered,
and I would say this
was the point at
which I realized
that I was writing a book,
was that on February 14, 1945,
Bernard Vonnegut was in
Minneapolis at a place called
the Ice Research Base, which,
just the idea that there
was an ice research base is
pretty excellent in my opinion.
But Bernard had been recruited.
He was doing secret war work for
the chemical warfare service.
And his research at the time
was studying aircraft deicing.
And of course, icing has
been a problem for aviation
since airplanes first
got up in the air.
And it continues to
be a problem, right?
The icing on the
pitot tube is what
brought down that Air France
airliner a few years back.
The military was
trying to figure out
how to deice their
bomber planes,
because they were flying over
Europe and getting iced over,
and it really was
screwing things up.
So Bernard was actually
in a bomber in Minneapolis
studying ways of
mitigating the ice
in order to keep
the bomber planes
in the air on the very day that
Kurt, of course, February 14,
1945, was in the slaughterhouse
basement in Dresden.
When he came up two
days later, this
is what Dresden looked like.
This, I think, was just-- that
was too compelling for me.
I had to follow up.
The reason that I knew that
Bernard was in Minneapolis
the day that the firebombing
of Dresden occurred
was because he wrote a letter
that day on hotel stationary
from the King Cole Hotel.
And he sent it to GE
labs in Schenectady.
Basically, he was
accepting a job offer.
As part of his
deicing research, he'd
started to work with some
GE scientists who were also
studying icing-- Irving Langmuir
and Vincent Schaefer at GE.
So as soon as the bombs
were dropped on Hiroshima
and Nagasaki, Bernard finished
up his military reports,
filed them, and became
a civilian again,
went to Schenectady to
work at General Electric.
This is General Electric today.
It's still there.
Downtown Schenectady,
the big GE monogram
glowing over Erie Boulevard.
I just kind of threw that in
'cause I like this picture,
and I do spend a
lot of time when
I'm researching a book
just randomly driving
around and taking photographs.
So I try to use them
because it makes
me feel like it was
a useful thing to do.
So those of you who haven't
heard of the GE Labs,
you've probably
heard of Bell Labs.
Bell Labs was one of these
pioneering industrial research
laboratories.
GE Labs, the GE Research Lab
was their first, in fact.
They were an
incredible organization
begun in the early 20th century
by Charles Proteus Steinmetz.
And the GE Lab
was kind of unique
among industrial
research laboratories
in that the scientists were
allowed to pursue research
that just interested them.
They were expected to
spend some time working
on making GE's light bulbs
better and stuff like that.
But they also were allowed to
just follow their passions.
They had something sort
of Google-y, right?
The were kind of like
20% time or something.
They were given the freedom to
pursue their own researches.
And those things often did
lead to new inventions for GE.
This is the hallway in the GE
Research Lab in about 1950.
The character, the
first guy on the left
there is Vincent Schaefer.
And the next guy down, kind
of impishly peeking out
of his office, is
Bernard Vonnegut.
Bernard had a personality
quite similar to Kurt.
He looks like his
brother, but he also
was kind of a-- he had
a great sense of humor
and a sense of
fun and jokes that
was fun to see, even in his
lab notebooks and things,
as I was researching the book.
So Bernard goes
off-- after the war,
Bernard goes off to work
at the GE Research Lab.
So it's still
looking like they're
going to follow these
trajectories that they're
in from the start.
The older brother
who's the A student
and the brilliant scientist, and
the younger brother who's kind
of flailing around.
Kurt came back from Dresden,
from his time as a POW,
and he really didn't know what
he wanted to do with himself.
All he knew for sure
was that he wanted
to marry Jane Cox, his childhood
sweetheart pretty much.
And so they quickly got married
when he got back from the war.
This is shortly before their
marriage, this photograph,
I think, but it's kind
of a great picture.
And then there's
this great series
of letters, because Kurt
was still in the Army
and right after their
wedding was sent out
to Fort Riley in Kansas.
And he and Jane
wrote back and forth
hundreds of letters
that are still
in the family's possession.
And they kind of show this
really interesting process
by which Jane convinced
Kurt to become a writer.
Kurt kept saying, you
know, I don't know.
I like writing, but really
I should have an office job.
Maybe I should go to law school.
Maybe I should study
something else.
I could probably be
good in human relations.
Why don't I become a
labor relations guy?
Why don't we open
a-- I like this idea.
For a while, he was into,
let's open a library slash bar.
He thought that would be really
cool, which it probably would.
And Jane just kept saying, no,
you're a really good writer.
You should write.
And you should make it your
goal to write for a living.
And he would be
like, don't say that.
That's really scary
when you say that,
because I could never do that.
And she slowly but
surely convinced
him to start taking himself
seriously as a writer.
So one of the things
he started doing
while he was at Fort
Riley in Kansas-- oh,
this is one of the letters.
The letters are so charming.
And he would draw these
little drawings on them.
Another thing funny thing
is that he was constantly
talking about how they
would have seven kids.
And he knew from the
time that they were 15
that they were going to get
married and have seven kids.
And if you know Kurt
Vonnegut's biography,
they did end up having seven
kids after they, Kurt and Jane,
had three, and his sister died
and they adopted her four.
So that's just kind of spooky,
like he really kind of was
time traveling at some point.
This letter was published in
the "New Yorker Page-Turner,"
an article I wrote.
So you can, if you are
interested in reading
it or having it, it's
on that newyorker.com.
Kurt started writing
short stories
while he was at Fort Riley
and sending them to Jane.
Jane would edit them and
retype them up and mail them
to editors at magazines.
And I just like this.
It's just a fun little detail.
He didn't have paper,
so he would type them
on the back of the
weather reports that
would roll off the teletype.
The story that's typed on the
back of this weather report
is called "Atrocity Story."
And it's about a guy who
steals a jar of string beans
while a POW in Dresden
and gets executed for it.
So if you've read
"Slaughterhouse-Five,"
you know that that's
kind of the dark heart
of "Slaughterhouse-Five,"
the execution of Edgar Derby
for stealing.
Kurt eventually makes
it a Dresden teapot,
which is even more absurd.
But this was based on
a real incident that
had happened to him as a POW.
He was forced to be one of the
people attending this execution
and bury the guy afterwards.
And he wrote this probably
almost 10 times in 10 different
ways before it became part
of "Slaughterhouse-Five."
So Kurt finishes, gets sent
home-- released from the Army,
and decides to go to
University of Chicago
and study anthropology.
Still kind of not
sure what he-- he's
still convincing, telling Jane
he's got to have a day job.
He's got to have some kind of
day job, because seven kids,
it's a lot to support.
Meanwhile, Bernard gets involved
in something very interesting
at the GE Lab.
Vincent Schaefer
and Irving Langmuir.
Irving Langmuir is perhaps
the most famous scientist
you may never have-- has anyone
heard of Irving Langmuir?
This would be an audience
where people have?
But yeah, not so many.
He's a Nobel laureate chemist
who worked for GE Labs.
And he was a household
name at this time.
He and his assistant,
Vincent Schaefer,
had decided they'd become
very interested in icing,
and specifically in cloud
behavior during the war.
And after the war
they decided, you
know, why don't we see
if we can figure out
why it is that super-cooled
clouds, clouds that
are cooled below the
temperature of freezing,
hang onto their moisture.
Often the water stays liquid.
It doesn't crystallize
and fall as snow.
So maybe we could figure
out why that happens
and see if we can affect it.
So they were experimentalists.
They decided, well, let's
just try some stuff.
So they got in a
freezer, which was
easy to get because
they worked at GE.
And they lined it
with black velvet
and they put a light on
it, and they breathed
into it which made a cloud.
And then they just
started spraying stuff
on this cloud to
see if any of it
would cause the
cloud to nucleate.
They had this theory that
the reason super-cooled
clouds produce rain eventually
is because something
is introduced into
the cloud that
provides a nucleus for
each little water droplet.
Water droplets cling to this
and that makes them heavy enough
to fall as rain.
It was kind of, I
don't know, it was just
kind of an intuitive sense
that they had watching clouds.
So they start trying stuff.
And they're spraying
things, different things,
different chemicals
on the cloud.
And it's going on and on
for a couple of months.
And then one day in July,
it's really, really hot
in the GE offices.
And Vincent's having
a hard time keeping
the freezer cold enough,
so he throws some dry ice
into the freezer.
And immediately,
the cloud turns into
a little miniature snowstorm.
It's all these
little snowflakes.
And he goes, wow,
dry ice did it.
And you can repeat this
experiment at home.
I did it while I was
working on the book
when someone sent me some
steaks, those steaks that
come with dry ice.
I was like, oh, going to
make some snow in my freezer.
And then it actually worked,
which was pretty neat.
So Bernard got involved.
They brought Bernard in.
And Bernard very
quickly discovered
that-- he went through the
crystallography handbook
and looked at all the
crystalline structures
of different chemicals,
and found the one that
was closest to water.
And that was silver iodide.
So he tried that on the little
cloud in the little freezer
and that did the same thing.
That actually caused the
cloud to precipitate.
So then they were
really excited.
They could not wait to go try
this in the actual atmosphere.
And they went out
in November of 1946
and they sprayed some
clouds with dry ice.
And sure enough,
it carved-- this
is a pattern of the
airplane carved in the cloud
by dropping dry ice.
So GE issues a press
release-- GE scientists have
learned to make snow and rain.
And basically, the
world reacts like this.
World weather control.
[LAUGHTER]
We're on the brink of
world weather control.
We've got it.
We've solved it.
We're finally doing
something about the weather.
And I mean, literally,
every newspaper--
the Boston Globe had like a
two-inch headline-- Snowstorm
Manufactured.
And it kind of seems silly
now, but looking back at it,
the scientists had just
harnessed the most fundamental
force in the universe, right?
They had just figured out
how to make an atomic bomb.
Nobody even knew that that
research was going on,
and then suddenly they did it.
So it just seemed
like yeah, science
is going to just go wild now.
So GE was inundated,
not only with clippings,
but with letters.
And the letters still
exist in the GE archive.
And they're hilarious,
because everybody wrote to GE,
and they were like, so
we're doing a film shoot
a Buffalo on December 6, and we
really would like it to snow,
because that's important.
Or we have a ski
slope in Vermont,
and we would really encourage
you to come here and practice
your experiments.
The nation of Chile
wrote and were like,
could you fix our deserts?
Could you guys send
some scientists
down here to fix our deserts?
And there were even
more interests--
there were moments where
there would be forest fires
and people would call GE.
Quick, we've got some
dry ice and an airplane,
and we're going to go up.
Tell us how to seed the clouds.
And the scientists would
try to talk them through it.
There was a plane crash on
Mount Rainier, a military plane.
And the military
called GE and said,
we want to clear the
clouds away so we can find
this airplane that crashed.
And the GE scientists
tried to give them advice.
So it was tremendous.
Bernard, at this
point, is famous.
He's appearing in
advertisements.
His career is in overdrive.
He's collecting patents for
various tools to do this.
And they're preparing to
completely manage the climate.
Around about this time, Kurt
Vonnegut's first son is born.
He's still a student at
the University of Chicago,
but the first of the
seven kids is here.
He's got anxiety about
supporting his family.
It was always really,
really important
to Kurt to support his family.
So he starts looking for a job .
And lo and behold, somebody
from she GE him and says,
your brother said that you
would be really a good person
in our publicity department.
Maybe you could
come work for us.
And the job was really good.
It was like too good
an offer to pass up.
Because Kurt Vonnegut always
wanted to be a newspaper man.
He had worked at his college
newspaper, his high school
newspaper.
While he was at the
University of Chicago,
he worked in the
city news bureau.
He was really comfortable
in a newsroom.
But a real newsroom is
not really a great job.
Being a real reporter is not
a great job for a family man.
This was kind of
like a happy medium,
because the GE News Bureau
was organized like a newsroom
except, of course,
they weren't objective.
But they had reporters.
They had beat
reporters whose-- you
beat would be like
lighting and refrigeration.
And you would go out and find
stories and report on them.
And you would write
up the stories
with pictures and
quotes and everything,
and then put them in an
envelope and send them
to editors all over the nation.
And newspaper and magazine
editors appreciated this.
It was free content.
And so GE was really
successful at this.
They are the nation's
biggest corporate publisher.
They were at the time.
And they were also
incredibly successful
in placing news stories.
So Kurt had a
science background.
He had a newsroom background.
And he had a need for a
safe, comfortable job.
So he took the job at
GE and he came to work.
He bought the house next
door to his brother's
and moved to Schenectady
with his wife and son.
The first thing
they did was they
went appliance shopping, because
he got an employee discount
at GE.
He writes his dad, he's
like, yeah, we got a fridge
and we got a washing machine.
And it's really cute.
So he starts being
a good company man,
going to work every day.
Wearing a three piece
suit and a fedora.
This is the GE newsroom.
Kurt's not in this
picture, but Bernard
is, because of course, those
are press photographs pinned up
to the wall back there.
And about half of them are
about Bernard's project.
It was GE'S biggest PR success.
This is Kurt at the time.
This is Kurt Vonnegut
at the time of this job,
in front of his house.
And it's not the Kurt
Vonnegut that we think
of when we think the Vonnegut.
We think of this kind of
rumpled, ironic, sarcastic,
chain smoking guy.
The chain smoking, yes.
He was definitely
already chain smoking.
But he was really trying
to be a good company man.
He was trying to tow
the corporate line,
to show the right
level of team spirit,
and not actually talk about
the fact that secretly,
at night and on weekends, he
was still writing short stories.
All he was getting was a
series of rejections, one
after the other.
He was writing story
after story that he
thought would appeal
to the slick magazines.
He and Jane would
study the magazines,
try to figure out what
the editors liked.
He produced stories, and the
editors just rejected them.
This went on for years.
And the Lilly Library
that has Kurt's papers
has a file called "rejection
letters," which for a writer
is just so affirming
to go through.
Because it's one rejection
after the other after the other.
It goes on and on and on.
And every now and then, there'd
be like a good rejection.
Like well, we kind of
liked this, but no.
And from all the big magazines.
I didn't have the foresight
when I was at the Lilly Library
to photograph the rejections.
So these are actually
my rejections
that I put in the slide show.
And I'm very proud
to say that they're
from some of the same
prestigious magazines
that rejected Kurt Vonnegut.
Meanwhile, Bernie-- and this
is kind of how the book works.
It goes back and forth with
these two narratives that
are kind of apart and
then they come together
at a certain point.
Bernie's project takes
an interesting turn,
because GE is thinking,
this is really
kind of not a great thing.
Our scientists are out there
making it snow, or rain,
or God knows what.
We could actually get sued.
And the lawyers were just
totally beside themselves.
They were apoplectic
about all of this.
So GE decides, let's
bring in the government.
And in fact, the arm
of the government
that's most interested
in weather control
is the military.
The GE scientists
are thinking, hey,
we're going to make
it rain in the desert.
If we can control
the weather, we
can stop hurricanes
from hitting the shore.
We can stop hail storms
that damage crops.
We can do all kinds
of great stuff.
The admirals and
the generals are
thinking, if we can
control the weather,
we could really
screw with Russia.
So here they are.
And I love the expression
on these guys' faces
as they're looking
into this fridge.
They came for the
little demonstration.
And Bernard in the
background there
is using a child's toy, a pop
gun, to precipitate the cloud.
Because he'd figured out
that that works as well.
And this is a
press photo that GE
took to announce that they
were handing this program
over to the military.
That their scientists were
no longer actually conducting
experiments.
That all of the experiments
were being conducted
by the military, specifically,
the Army Signal Engineer Corps.
And it would be done on military
planes with military pilots.
And so GE was sort of
insulated from lawsuits
by this wall of military brass,
which made them very happy.
It was kind of a win
for Project Cirrus,
as they gave the name, because
you can't have a weather
control project without
a kind of sci-fi name--
super-secret sci-fi name.
So they gave it the
name Project Cirrus,
and they got military
planes and pilots.
And here they are loading a
B17 bomber plane with dry ice
to go on a seeding run.
Here's Vincent Schaefer
installing into the B17
a cloud droplet
meter that Bernie
had invented to measure
the number of droplets
in the clouds as they're
flying through them.
And here's Bernie--
I love this picture.
Sort of Bernard Vonnegut
as Doctor Strangelove
meets Flash Gordon--
on the plane,
getting ready to go up there
and bombard some clouds.
Because of course,
the GE scientists
were totally out there
doing the experiments,
but officially, they
were just consultants.
So the first thing
that they-- and this
must have been
weird for Bernard,
too, because now he's
on the same planes that
were raining down
death on his brother,
trying to accomplish
something, he hopes,
for the good of humanity.
The first thing they
decide to do now
that they have all this
new military hardware
is something they'd
been hoping they
could do from the start, which
is cloud seed a hurricane.
The idea was if you
could attack a hurricane,
you could maybe steer it.
A hurricane contains more energy
than a thermonuclear bomb.
So you're not going
to ever control it.
But you could possibly
like divert it
so that it would go away from
land instead of towards land.
So they spend the whole
hurricane season of 1947
waiting for the right
hurricane, like, we
need a hurricane
that we can go--
and finally, one comes through.
And they jump on planes.
And they fly down to the
military base in Florida.
And the hurricane has
come up through the gulf,
it's crossed the tip of Florida,
and it's chugging out to sea
in a northeasterly direction.
And they fly out there and they
seed it, they cloud seed it.
And the point at
which they cloud
seed it is the point at which
makes that dog leg turn left.
And it comes back to shore.
It just turns around, comes back
to shore, slams into Savannah,
hits Charleston, destroys
a whole bunch of planes
at the airport.
Millions of dollars
worth of property damage.
A guy's killed by
a falling tree.
It's a disaster.
It's a total disaster.
And everyone down
there is furious
because it's been reported that
Project Cirrus is coming down
to see if they can
steer a hurricane.
The mayor of Savannah
says, if anybody from GE
shows up in Savannah, he's
going to throw them in jail.
Another journalist says,
it's a low Yankee trick,
which of course,
like they're still
fighting the Civil War, right?
So GE gets all the
scientists on the plane,
flies them back to
Schenectady, pushes them out
in a press talk.
And they're like,
no, we did not seed.
No, we didn't see the hurricane.
We were just looking
at the hurricane.
We really-- nope, nope.
They just deny, deny, deny.
And so that's kind of
an interesting moment,
I think, for Bernie.
Because suddenly
it becomes clear
that even if your goal
is not to make a weapon,
you might make one by mistake.
Because the atmosphere
is really unpredictable.
On the other hand,
the entire world
is really excited about
the fact that weather
is going to be our
next big super weapon.
And people are
going around saying,
this is more important
than the atomic bomb.
And I love this
cover of "Collier's."
This is the kind of thing
that everyone's envisioning.
We're just going to be at
our control panel here.
And this is written
by a military man.
This is how we're going
to dominate the world.
This is about the time
that Kurt Vonnegut
decides to write a new kind
of story, a kind of story that
features a scientist.
And the scientist is kind of
faced with an ethical dilemma.
And that is, he's invented
something new and cool,
but it could go wrong.
It could get out of his hands.
It could do something
really-- or it
could be co-opted to
be used as a weapon.
He writes a story called "Report
on the Barnhouse Effect,"
in which a scientist
discovers that he
can control something
that was previously
thought to be undiscoverable.
He hopes to use his power
for humanity's good.
And the military gets
involved and wants
to use it as a super weapon.
They take over, they give
it a sci-fi-like code name.
They call it Project
Wishing Well,
and they start trying to conduct
experiments to figure out
how to weaponize it.
And professor Barnhouse has
to figure out what to do.
This is Kurt Vonnegut's
first published story.
He finally gets it right.
He finally cracks the code.
And in the meantime, starts
developing the voice that we
think of as Kurt Vonnegut, and
the science fictional strategy
that we think of as
particularly Vonnegut's.
And it's not really science
fiction of the old science
fiction type, with like set
in alien worlds and space
wars and stuff.
All he does is he
takes the things
that he's seeing at GE, and
particularly the dilemmas
that he's seeing his brother
go through, and amps them
up a little in order to
surface their ethical issues.
For instance, GE is
the first corporation
that owned a
differential analyzer,
as they called it then.
A very early computer.
It was a room-sized,
extremely noisy computer.
The programmers, however,
dressed very well,
as you can see, to work on it.
This computer was
called OMIBAC, which
is ordinal memory inspection--
binary inspection computer,
or something like that.
I can't remember
exactly what it is.
But all the computers
at this time
had names like
this-- ENIAC, EDVAC.
So OMIBAC is GE'S computer.
Kurt writes a story
about a computer
called EPICAC--
and this also sells
as a successful
story-- that falls
in love with its programmer's
object of affection,
and is cranking out, in this
illustration from the story,
is cranking out
love poetry for her.
EPICAC then goes on to become
the name of the computer
in "Player Piano" that
controls everything.
Kurt writes a story,
and this story
is actually in the
GE house magazine,
written by Kurt Vonnegut, but
unsigned, about ultrasonics.
GE was just starting to enter
into research into ultrasonic.
And Kurt did the press
release and story about it.
And then around
about the same time,
he writes a short story called
"The Euphio Question" in which
there's a radio wave
invented that's really
this great sounding radio wave.
And when people
hear it they just
drop whatever they're doing and
they lie around and bliss out
listening to this radio wave.
And so it's this huge
disrupting force.
So again, he's
like saying, well,
there's this new
technology, but what if.
How it might go wrong?
There's another story
called "Thanasphere"
about a scientist who is
working for the military,
helping them put a manned
satellite in space.
Its job is to keep
tabs on the weather.
But what the man inside
the satellite finds out
is that space is actually
full of the dead.
There are all these voices
of the dead up there
that want to be heard.
The military men
can't let this out
because they don't
want to admit that they
have a satellite, because the
Russians might not like that.
So they actually bring
it down and kill the guy.
The scientist in this
story is named Bernard.
So this was really fun for me.
As you can imagine,
I totally geeked out
and spent a few months knocking
around in the GE archive,
and discovering many
of the source material
sources for the early
Vonnegut short stories.
So when I gave this
talk at Vonnegut fest,
it was sort of like a,
identify this story.
Because there was
the time that a deer
gets into the factory at
GE and has to be removed.
And the press,
the GE news bureau
is called over to report on it.
This, of course,
becomes the first story
that Kurt sold to "Esquire"
called "Deer in the Works."
There's the GE sales force
refrigerator that walks
and talks and travels around.
There's a salesman who
travels around with it.
And it's just a little PR stunt.
Kurt-- and here is starting
to get really clever.
He turns it into a female,
which then makes it
into kind of a sexy sexbot,
and the salesman who
travels with it loses his
ability to relate to real women
because he's so in
love with his fridge.
It's like an early version
of Scarlett Johansson
as an operating system.
This poor guy is an air
conditioning engineer
who really loved model trains.
And Kurt reports on
his model train hobby,
and then he writes
a story called
"With his Hand on the
Throttle" about a guy who's
so obsessed with model trains
that he ignores his wife.
And this is Liaquat Ali Khan,
the first prime minister
of Pakistan, who comes to
the United States in 1950
and is given a state tour.
He's trotted all
around the country.
He's taken to see an average
American family in Kansas City.
He's taken to see the Tomb
of the Unknown Soldier.
He meets the president.
He meets Eisenhower,
General Eisenhower,
whose then president
of Columbia University.
He goes to see farms and
factories and prize cattle.
And eventually, of course,
washes up on the shores of GE,
where they take him to see
a worker driving rivets
into an enormous flywheel.
Liaquat Ali Khan is
assassinated one year later.
No one's ever really
figured out who did it,
but the point at which Liaquat
Ali Khan is assassinated
is the point at
which Kurt decides
to write the Shah of
Bratpuhr into "Player Piano."
And the Shah of Bratpuhr is
given the same exact state tour
that Liaquat Ali Khan was
given when he came in 1950.
And then, of course, there was
GE's corporate retreat center
on Association Island,
where you arrived
and you were issued your GE
t-shirt and your straw boater.
I'm not sure what
the boater was about,
but you had to have your boater.
Every year the promising
young men of GE
would be taken to
Association Island
for an orgy of team building
and corporate pep rallies.
This is, of course,
the meadows, the source
for the meadows in
"Player Piano," which
is just almost a word for
word transcription of what
it was like to be at
Association Island.
It was so mercilessly
skewered in "Player Piano"
that GE closed Association
Island a few years later.
And Kurt Vonnegut,
in later life,
took total credit for that.
He was like, yep, one good thing
came out of my writing at GE.
I got them to shut down
that stupid island.
But the most famous thing that
came out of his time at Ge
was ice-nine.
Ice-nine, of course, is the
premise of "Cat's Cradle,"
really his breakthrough
book published in 1963.
And Kurt always told the
story about how ice-nine
was actually Irving
Langmuir's idea.
This is Irving Langmuir who
was "Time's" Man of the Week
for his weather projects.
Ice-nine was an idea that
Irving Langmuir came up
with to entertain HG Wells.
When HG Wells was touring
the GE factor in the 1930s,
he was given Langmuir
as his guide.
And Langmuir said he
figured out-- he thought,
I don't really know
how to talk to a writer
because I'm a scientist.
So I guess when you
talk to writers,
you just have to give
them new ideas for books.
So he said, hey, HG Wells, I
have a great idea for a book.
How about a book
about a form of ice
that's stable and solid
at room temperature.
And it gets loose and
it destroys the world.
And HG Wells, was like, eh, eh.
And so the story was told.
There were lots of stories
told about Irving Langmuir
because he was
famously absent-minded.
He would step in a
can of paint and just
pull his foot out
and keep walking.
Or there was a famous story
about how a woman on the stairs
fell down in front
of him and he just
like stepped over
her and kept going.
He would not recognize you
if he was deep in thought.
He was a classic scientist
with his head in the clouds.
So he was also the source
for Felix Hoenikker
in "Cat's Cradle."
And this story about ice-nine
was told around the GE cocktail
circuit.
Kurt heard it and
thought, finders keepers.
But the real ice-nine is
actually Bernie's invention.
This is Bernie using
a hydrogen generator
to light his silver iodide.
Because he'd found that
if you aerosolize it,
turn it into a smoke,
it works even better
to precipitate the clouds.
And when Kurt asked Bernie
to explain his invention,
Bernie explained it.
He said, well, the
molecules in ice,
when it becomes
crystalline, they
can lock in
different formations.
Think about cannonballs
on a courthouse lawn.
You could stack them in
different formations.
And that's kind of why we have
these different crystalline
forms of ice.
We have ice-one,
ice-two, ice-three.
At the time, ice,
there were only five
known crystalline forms.
And so, in "Cat's Cradle"
that's exactly how
ice-nine is explained,
in Bernard's exact words.
So Bernard, during
all of this time,
is deeply concerned about the
weaponization of his cloud
seeding project.
And I threw in some slides about
something else I geeked out
on while I was
working on this book,
because there was actually
a competing weather control
project going on at the time.
This is John von Neumann,
who was one of the first five
members of the Institute for
Advanced Study in Princeton,
New Jersey.
Famous brilliant mathematician.
So smart people thought that
he probably wasn't even human.
von Neumann was actually working
on a weather control project
that he'd had knocking around
in his head since 1946.
His idea was very,
very different
from the GE scientists.
The GE scientists
were experimentalists.
They were empiricists.
They were like, let's go
out and spray the clouds
with some stuff and
see what happens.
von Neumann thought, you
know, the weather is simply
a problem of fluid dynamics.
And he knew a lot
about fluid dynamics.
von Neumann actually
did the math
that proved the
implosion theory that
was used on the plutonium
bomb, Fat Man, that
was dropped on Nagasaki.
He was part of the
Manhattan Project.
He was already thinking about
the thermonuclear bomb, which
he and Edward Teller
were convinced should be
built before anyone else was.
Von Neumann wanted
to build a computer.
He wanted to build a
super-fast computer,
because he wanted it
to do the calculations
for the thermonuclear bomb.
And there was no computer
with enough computing power
yet to do it.
But he thought he had an
architecture that would work.
He needed, however,
a public thing
for the computer to work on.
He needed a public reason
for this computer to happen.
So he approached
the weather bureau.
He said, I've got
this great idea.
We could use the computer
to forecast the weather.
Because the weather is
a deterministic system.
And once we've got enough data
and enough computing power,
we will be able-- and obviously,
I'm shortcutting a lot here--
but we'll be able to predict
the weather infinitely.
And once we can do that, we will
be able to control the weather.
Because it will surely have
instabilities in the system.
Freeman Dyson was
a young physicist
at the Institute for Advanced
Study at the same time.
He heard von Neumann
give a talk at the time.
And he kind of summarized
it as, all stable systems
we shall predict.
All unstable systems
we shall control.
So von Neumann gets together
two groups of people.
The first is a group
of meteorologists.
These are the meteorologists who
are going to produce the math.
Because of course, the math
for modeling the weather
didn't yet exist.
So they had to get together
the best and the brightest
of meteorologists to come
up with the equations
that they would feed
to the computer.
The first round
of equations where
fed, actually, to ENIAC, because
John von Neumann's computer
wasn't done yet.
And when I was looking
at the log books,
I just thought this was using.
The ENIAC-- this is
why Jon von Neumann
wanted to build a new computer.
It's like 14:05 ENIAC
down, 14:15 still no ENIAC.
It was so hard working
with this computer.
So in 1952, von Neumann's
computer is finished.
This thing is a Ferrari in
a land that has only seen
horse and carriages so far.
I mean, this was a
beautiful-- this is
what's called the IAS machine.
It actually is now at
the Smithsonian Museum
of American History.
And those things
along the bottom
are Williams cathode ray tubes.
That's the memory.
There were 40 of those
adding up to a total
of five kilobytes of memory.
Five whole kilobytes.
This was a supercomputer.
And it was so compact.
It only weighed a couple tons.
It was eight feet long
and two feet wide.
It's a beauty.
von Neumann was
very proud of it.
And he fed his equations into
it and began predicting weather.
However, he was best friends
with another guy, Norbert
Wiener, a mathematician
at MIT, who
thought, you know
what, you're never
going to be able to predict
the weather infinitely,
because the weather
is really unstable.
And it's just got all these
tiny little instabilities in it
that are going to
magnify at great speed.
So you might be able
to predict the weather
for, Wiener thought 30 days.
It turns out it's
two weeks, right?
We can predict the
weather with some accuracy
for two weeks out.
And then it just
all goes to hell.
It's a funny thing.
Wiener and John von
Neumann were best friends.
They were very, very different.
Wiener was a famous
pacifist who, after the war,
famously refused to
share his research
work with anyone in the military
or defense contractors at all.
And he wrote famous
articles about this.
von Neumann, of course, was
the military's right hand man.
One person who really
agreed with Wiener,
who thought that he was kind
of a hero, was Kurt Vonnegut.
Kurt Vonnegut read Wiener's
book "Cybernetics."
"Cybernetics" is a book
that kind of nobody
reads anymore, because it's
conclusions are so much
now a part of our DNA that
we don't even have to think
about it or talk about it.
But he basically was
one of the first people
to say, look, the brain
is a kind of computer
and a computer is
a kind of brain.
And Wiener also wanted to think
about the moral issues of this.
If computers start
doing-- if machines
are doing our physical
labor, and computers
begin doing our mental
labor, what kind of world
will we have?
What will happen to humanity?
What kind of people
will we turn into?
He was thinking hard about
these things in "Cybernetics."
And then he was encouraged
to write a version of it
without the math that was
called "The Human Use of Human
Beings."
Kurt was a big fan of
Wiener and of "Cybernetics,"
and when he wrote
"Player Piano,"
he actually quotes
Wiener at a couple points
in "Player Piano."
He sent the book
to Norbert Wiener,
thinking that Wiener
would love it.
Because Kurt was
basically saying,
in a fictional form,
exactly what Wiener
was saying in his own work.
Much to his chagrin,
Wiener hated the book.
And he sent him a
really nasty letter
that's still extant-- it's
at MIT in his papers--
where he said, playing
around with this fiction,
whatever, not very serious.
But the real
objection that he had,
and he went on and
on about it, was
there's a character in "Player
Piano" who writes a manifesto.
And the manifesto
is basically taken
from Norbert Wiener's work.
It sounds exactly
like Norbert Wiener,
in which he's saying
human beings need to think
of themselves as human beings.
They need to consistently
remind themselves
that they're human beings.
And not let technology take
their essential humanity away
from them.
Kurt Vonnegut name that
character Ludwig von Neumann.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Which I have to think
was done ironically,
because von Neumann
was very excited
about self-replicating automata.
He wrote a famous
paper about it.
In any case, Wiener
was a skeptic
not only about Kurt Vonnegut,
but about weather control.
He really thought that
weather control was not
going to happen.
The system was too unstable.
And even weather prediction
was going to be hard.
Bernard Vonnegut is starting
to think the same thing.
And one of the reasons
he's starting to think that
is because as soon as weather
control became a thing,
people were making the
pilgrimage nonstop to GE
to find out how to seed clouds.
So New York City is
seeding the Catskills
to fill their reservoirs.
People in the Great Plains
are seeding the clouds
to try to steer
away hail storms.
This is some people
from New Mexico
who came to-- they
were, of course, having
a drought because they
live in New Mexico.
They were coming to check out,
thinking that they could seed
the clouds and fix New Mexico.
Bernard is starting to
think, well, you know,
we're stinking up the whole
atmosphere of the nation
with silver iodide.
What could we actually be doing?
What might be
happening out there?
This is a map that
he made in 1951
showing the areas
in the United States
that were under cloud
seeding contracts.
So this is where
people were going out,
spraying massive amounts
of silver iodide,
because nobody knew how much
or how little you could use.
They were just going out.
There was one congressman who
would go out with dry ice,
like in a yogurt container,
and used a teacup to throw it
out the window of a Cessna.
And then if it rained, he would
land and jump out of the plane
and go up to the
ranchers and be like,
I just made you that rain.
There were astonishing
things going on.
And Bernard was really
interested in finding out
what was actually happening.
He thought that their work
and that the work of all
these amateurs
might, in fact, be
changing be atmospheric
dynamics of North America.
And he started saying this.
And people, of course, said to
him, well, don't be ridiculous.
Nothing that humans
do could change
the atmospheric dynamics.
I mean, that's the whole climate
we're talking about, right?
So I'm going to leave you there.
I hope I have time if
there are questions.
That's pretty much an outline
of the first half of the book.
What happens in
the second half is
Kurt continues to
write short stories
and writes "Player Piano"
about what he's seeing at GE.
And Bernard becomes
more and more convinced
that he has to do something.
And he kind of figures
out what, in part,
through his conversations and
relationship with his brother.
So I'm just curious to know
how many people in the room
are Vonnegut fans?
Interesting.
So Vonnegut fans who've read
more than two of the books?
All of the books?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: How many are there?
GINGER STRAND: I don't even
know the answer to that.
There are a lot.
I was talking to someone who
was a fan of the short stories,
which is I think the Vonnegut
that most people don't read.
But the short stories
are pretty fun.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
Was there tension
between Bernard and Kurt,
because here's Bernard working
as this corporate scientist.
I mean, at some point these
stories start coming out,
and their kind of
goofing on the whole sort
of military industrial complex.
Did Bernard ever feel any
sort of pressure or tension
that he's got this corporate
job as an in-house scientist,
and yet his brother, who's at
some point also employed by GE,
is writing these
stories that are kind
of mocking the whole thing?
GINGER STRAND: Yeah,
there was quite a bit
of, I think, tension felt,
both of their parts in a way.
Because Bernard agreed with
Kurt, but he loved his job.
And he loved working
at GE, but at the risk
of giving you spoilers,
he does quit eventually.
And it's partly because of
exactly the same things that
drove Kurt to quit,
not wanting to be
part of that corporate
world, and not wanting
to be told that he had to
work with the military,
that he had to do whatever the
corporation wanted him to do.
So I would say that most of
the anxiety was on Kurt's part.
And there's a very funny letter
that Kurt wrote to his editor
when "Player Piano"
was about to come out.
Which is the dark
night of the soul
that you always have when
your first book comes out
as a writer.
You're like, holy
crap, what have I done?
Like people are
going to read this
and I've exposed
myself or my whatever.
And so he writes this holy
crap letter to his editor.
And he says, you can never tell
anybody that I worked for GE,
because GE has a
hostage-- my brother.
So anyway.
Thanks so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]